sur le plan de la météo 2022 a démarré
en lion en janvier coup sur coup trois
tempêtes hivernales viennent enterrer
les provinces atlantiques sous la neige
ou sous la pluie et paralyser les
activités quotidiennes de dizaines de
milliers de citoyens
au printemps c'est le même Toba qui
accuse le coup le sud de la province à
les pieds dans l'eau les rivières
deviennent des lacs des chansons
submergés et il faut déclarer l'état
d'urgence dans une trentaine de
municipalités
Québécois et les Ontariens ajoute un
nouveau mot à leur vocabulaire le derret
show une tempête brève et violente qui
laisse un million d'abonnés sans
électricité et cause un milliard de
dollars de dommages un délu c'était la
fin du monde des enfants de la maison ça
pleurait c'était la panique Brive en
juillet les incendies s'allument d'abord
dans l'ouest du pays puis dans l'Est
Athènes qui secoué par l'ampleur des
événements
mais c'est un septembre que la nature
frappe le plus fort lorsque les
Maritimes encaissent de plein fouet le
choc de la tempête Fiona
on observe des vins qui atteignent 170
km à l'heure des torrents de pluie 80%
des habitants de la Nouvelle-Écosse et
presque 100% de ceux de lait du prince
et doigt subissent des pannes de courant
va voir beaucoup de travail à faire dans
les prochains jours et les prochains
mois pour nettoyer et rebâtir au final
2022 aurait été une année climatique
très turbulente à l'image des dernières
qui ont tout été fortement influencés
par le réchauffement planétaire je suis
certaine que l'année prochaine on on va
être en train de discuter de plusieurs
événements météo aussi catastrophiques
aussi dévastateurs et extrême que sur
les années précédentes donc c'est
vraiment selon moi ça va suivre la
tendance que qui est présent depuis
quelques années ici normand Grondin
Radio-Canada Montréal